hazeaux et comment vous êtes combien d
être en voie de l'être et bien sûr donc
gilles échos jusque 7 bulldozers caïla
j'ai une magnifique surprise peau j'ai
trouvé le cadeau qu'il te fall là bas
est ce que tu veux un premier indice
regarde
jean rachid de genève et bruno si je te
dis cette phrase l'amour c'est comme un
gros rhume ça s'attrape dans la rue et
ça se finit aux libéraux stomy bugzy mon
frère notre frère il n'irait ce que tu
vois de quoi ce tome i et notre frère
veut parler c'est tout de toi ou on le
sait ce que tu vas deuxième indice
voilà ce que tu reconnais cette photo
cette photo floutée
voilà bah oui bah oui c'est qui est
ma première fiancée la première fiancée
et ça c'est toi là d'abord là ouais mais
flouté flouté c'est ta première fiancée
de passagers est ce qu'on peut avoir un
bon jour de la surprise
c'est une personne
bonjour brunoh bonjour
ce que vous pouvez nous redire bonjour
bonjour bonjour tu reconnais c'est toi
non est ce que tu sais qui est cette
personne
vous allez faire venir un four un truc
comme ça c'est une vraie vraie surprise
puisque c'est quelqu'un qui est venu de
dire quelque chose
c'est vrai oui on a retrouvé
oui qui était sur tes genoux la whey ton
premier amour c'est vrai oui et bien ton
premier amour et là ce soir
zack wright avec ma pudeur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est alors c'est vrai premier ah bon
vous êtes magnifique alors alors bruno
[Applaudissements]
eibel même si vous êtes la première
petite amie de doc d'eau qu'est ce que
ça te fait quelque chose que tu es
heureux de la revoir toujours oui ça
fait énormément plaisir tu l'a pas revu
depuis combien de temps quelques années
moment c'est en quelle année ça combien
de temps après ça fait combien de temps
à quai à peu près ça 15 à ça ça fait 15
ans ouais cost et sa première souci de
date
cette photo date de vous n'êtes pas vu
depuis quinze ans mais c'était mon
premier amour
c'est à quel âge on avec les loges avec
elle a 15 ans et 15 ans c'est incroyable
et comment vous êtes co bientôt être en
citera de l'est
bien sûr
[Musique]
il est évident qu'il ya là où vous êtes
venu quand je te laisse pas content
parce que lui il se rappelle plus ça
pourra alors les a aussi cogné aux puces
de clignancourt au plus de clients que
moi vous faisiez quoi je faisais je
faisais le dimanche allait souvent pu
saler loin et lui faisait quoi il était
assis à l'entrée du passé sinon à faire
sur un trottoir par terre sur un trou
noir
c'était donc bien lui et donc il à quoi
bon ces bassins il est ex tome i way et
ils m'ont suivi en fait et après j'étais
avec une amie j'ai dit à mon ami si
jamais il arrivait à nous dis leur que
je suis sourde et muette et alors ils
sont arrivés vers vous qu'est ce qui
s'est passé il m'a fait rire tout de
suite c'est vrai il a dit quoi tu veux
boire quelque chose ce serait un truc
comme ça note actuelle dit quoi d'autre
j'ai parlé langage des signes tout de
suite c'est vrai mais si c'est parler le
langage des signes et vous a tout de
suite voulu la revoir je l'aimé tout de
suite au premier regard dans la lah
alors il y avait pas de portable à
l'époque n'ont donc vous avez dû donner
votre 0 1 c'est ça non mais franchement
assez ça vous est donné votre numéro
fixe
oui et nos adresses il venait tout le
temps bâtiment et quoi il était tout en
bas de chez vous ouais ouais ouais t'as
problème
zakia vous êtes venus ce soir à pour
faire une surprise à doc et je crois que
cette surprise lui fait extrêmement
plaisir mais vous êtes venus également
pour lui dire quelque chose
oui oui
à l'egypte je voulais te dire que toutes
ces années même si toi tu avais pas de
nouvelles de moi moi j'en avais grâce à
ta notoriété donc j'ai toujours suivi et
on s'était fait une promesse titre apple
s'était fait une promesse et je voulais
juste dire moi ma promesse veulent à
tenir c'est moi et que je t'aime j'ai
toujours aimé suis fier de toi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais
[Applaudissements]
et surtout s'en émut monde aucun écho
temps c'est pas à nous que ça arriverait
si vous êtes resté vous allez rester
copains donc maintenant vous avez les
bons vins ce père c'est vrai que vous
l'avez jamais oublier non jamais
j'aimerais le manoir on oublie pas c'est
vrai qu'on n'oublie pas tu as quelque
chose à dire à zac est atteint oui oui
en fait oui je vais tenir notre promesse
mais c'est quoi la promesse parce que
nous on n'était pas là donc j'ai fait
elle est censée quoi qu'il arrive dans
la vie toujours toujours toujours se
voir toujours toujours se voir j'aurais
transcende
c'est à dire soit qu'il arrive on a dit
qu'on resterait même sans être là à côté
de l'autre de se protéger
c'est ma force mystérieuse
franchement ils sont
[Applaudissements]
le périphérique oui il est exceptionnel
c'est un être exceptionnel devrait
renaître c'est un bon sens vraiment je
vous dis je suis très heureux parce que
j'avais rarement vu bruno comme ça dans
les grès rose je suis content de t'avoir
fait plaisir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors les chéris cyril regarder issam ça
se voit oui oui c'est de l'amitié
calmez vous il est avec quelqu'un c'est
tout le monde est d'avis que vous êtes
avec quelqu'un maintenant à cas
justement non non vous êtes célibataire
oui un accord et tout le monde sait
qu'on n'allait pas la gâcher
[Musique]